pierre-jean chalencon qui est avec nous
si vous aimez napoléon c'est simple un
conseil allez vous installer cher pierre
g en chalencon où il y aurait
l'impression de vivre avec napoléon
toujours gardé
[Musique]
on commence la visite du château
extraordinaire château impérial avec une
tapisserie des gobelins offerte par
napoléon maréchal berthier en 1812
c'est superbe c'est d'une qualité
extraordinaire là vous avez le buste du
patron parce que pour moi c'est le
patron à chaque fois que je j'arrive ici
je touche toujours la tête de napoléon
c'est un signe de ralliement peut-être
j'ai la chance d'avoir l'une des toutes
premières lettres connues napoléon
bonaparte à l'âge de 15 ans où il donne
son emploi du temps à l'école militaire
de paris et la signature rarissime où il
signa pour leonetti bois n'a pas
extraordinaire les cheveux des napoléons
là ils sont dans une petite boîte qui
appartenait la soeur de napoléon elle
les a coupés en 1814 à l'île d'elbe
alors je sors les cheveux c'est
important d'avoir la provenance plus la
provenance est bonne plus les cheveux
sont rares et recherchés par les
collectionneurs ou les musées ou les
analystes
un oasis est blond il était plutôt
châtain châtains roux même est alors ses
cheveux ont une histoire ils ont été
analysés sont en train d'être analysé et
dans quelques semaines on connaîtra si
oui ou non il a été assassiné
arsenic et vieilles dentelles alors là
je vous prends je monte le lean napoléon
son lit de campagne qu'il avait quand il
était même aux tuileries fils qui
dormait dans son lit
vous avez la chemise de napoléon
merveilleux chemise qui est même tachés
de sang c'est une des dernières chemise
d'un pont avec le caleçon l'empereur
vous prenez pas un peu trop pour naples
et voilà je me prends rarement pour la
volée on mais quand j'ai son chapeau
effectivement toews on pourrait dire que
je pourrais me promener dans la rue mais
j'ai une plus grosse tête que lui
30 je ne peux malheureusement pas mettre
son chapeau
oh
faut savoir une napoléon aimait manger
dans de l'argent pris bien sûr l'époque
c'était de l'argent pris mais ce sont
ses couverts qui sont ces ses couverts
personnel à waterloo la bataille de
waterloo
mais il mangeait très mal en fin de
compte il buvait très mal puisque le vin
il le coupait à de l'eau ils mangeaient
le midi imaginez-vous entre cinq et sept
minutes le soir entre 12 et 15 et dire
que quand vous étiez invité à malmaison
et bien il fallait mieux manger avant
d'ailleurs il était de bon ton de manger
avant et joséphine ça c'est assez
amusant joséphine jusqu en 1809 et bien
suis l'étiquette de la cour
mais à partir de 1809 et le divorce elle
est toute seule elle à prendre 20 kilos
et elle devient une grosse dinde ont
alors vous avez de la place forgé la
place pour moi en fait voilà ma chambre
c'est une petite chambre mais voyez je
suis toujours réveillé par un homme
merveilleux qui met bluey chaque matin
c'est les rayons du soleil d'austerlitz
si oui pour moi chaque matin c'est
l'empereur par bach le baron gérard
jodar mais là je dors l'âge alors la
voyez je suis dans mon livre c'est on
est bien c'est merveilleux je n'attends
plus que ma joséphine
alors hier jean
c'est de la rage
voilà vous consacrez quoi toute votre
vie vous aussi à napoléon économie si
j'ai envie de dire tout je mange des
pâtes
je ne ferai pas de pattes de pub pour
les pattes mais bon c'est vrai toute ma
vie 24 heures sur 24 depuis l'âge de
huit ans en fait je suis tombé dedans
mes parents m'avaient offert une bande
dessinée
et puis après tout les week end c'était
malmaison c'était les invalides et puis
maintenant j'essaie de vivre c'est pas
évident mais c'est vrai que grâce à tous
ces bicentenaire on arrive à organiser
des expositions des ventes aux enchères
à des spectacles enfin je suis très
heureux alors qu'hier gens venus avec
quelques objets qu'on va regarder oui je
vous ai apporté sur votre position tout
à fait alors en fait je vous ai apporté
le portefeuille dans lequel on apportait
les décrets allant de l'empereur pour
les signer est-ce qu'on peut encore
trouver des objets ayant appartenu
naples est moins brillante oui je vous
invite le 17 novembre prochain
fontainebleau gratuit il ya une chemise
de l'empereur qui va être vendu il va y
avoir un mouchoir y avoir plein d'objets
sûr que c'est une chemise rassurer
certains lé pa tachés de sang celle là
sinon vous venir chez moi mais sinon on
n'y a aucun problème aujourd'hui dans le
monde entier sont des américains ce sont
des japonais énormément d'étrangers et
les français s'y mettent
mais monsieur pinault que s'est mis à
financer enfin financer le spectacle de
robert hossein
superbe avec fabrizio qui en junkie
extraordinaire qui ressemble à bonaparte
je n'ai pas coupé de cheveux pour le
moment mais je vais essayer la prochaine
fois oui alors là je vous ai apporté
quelque chose d'extraordinaire qui et
c'est un mot qui revient souvent dans la
bouche mais c'est vrai c'est le premier
testament de napoléon à sainte-hélène et
on parle de napoléon comme un homme au
quotidien bien vu aux agents napoléon se
pencha seraient très fort bien voilà et
bien c'est le premier testament de
napoléon avec la plume original c'est la
plume qui vient des collections du grand
maréchal bertrand et dans ce testament
il est de l'argent à ses amis y laissent
des objets à son fils et ses mémoires
arrive en troisième position pour
messieurs les historiens pour ça c'est
un un document important
il ya aussi quelque chose d'assez
amusant pendant son voyage de noces avec
marie louise et bien ils pensent pas à
folâtrer pourtant ils auront un enfant
mais il se met à créer il crée la banque
d'italie en le 9810 à bergholtz home
alors ça c'est assez amusant aussi et je
voulais amener la chevalière mme de
sécheval iran en brillant qui a été
réalisé en 1810 par chaumet la maison
chaumet et c'est très élégant donc je
cherche une épouse éventuellement je
suis prêt à laisser il faut qu'elle ait
menacé son salon c'est fini a sinon
c'est fini effectivement vous êtes
totalement dépassée quand vous voyez ça
ne complètement règlement j'ai les
cheveux et le meilleur alors j'ai les
cheveux de l'ordre alors d'ici quelques
semaines on va savoir si oui ou non il a
été assassiné
voilà alors ça a pu surmonter un terrier
alors je les ouvre
mais j'espère sur la mer
damages oléron voilà innovant pension
cynique et voilà merci
tiens j'en challans ans donc il ya une
vente bientôt pour terminer la mission
7,9 en barre
[Musique]